yesterday we reintroduced this idea of
um functions relations and then we sort
of moved into inverse functions right
so we looked at it in a couple of
different ways first we thought about it
conceptually
right it's all about this input out good
idea and swapping them around okay and
um it literally it inverts the process
it flips it upside down so
you take something and then you get
something out and then you say well what
would reverse that what would give you
your original thing if you provided the
result right so that's kind of the
concept of an inverse function
we also looked at the nuts and bolts of
how to turn a function into its inverse
we looked at that algebraically right
so for instance it's a y for instance
with this which you've all done right
how would we rewrite this using uh
inverse function notation well you'd say
let's swap the um f and the x right so
you'd have your x over here and your
whoops two of them
your two lots of the inverse over there
subtract four so all that done is a
straight swap and then you just
rearrange to make um f inverse the
subject which would look like this
put that over there
and then you can have the thing
okay no problems right so we let the
concept we learned how to work with it
algebraically
today we want to think about how it
works geometrically we want to look at
it
see if we can work out some of the
properties of inverse functions in
relation to the original function okay
so the tool we're going to use the means
we're going to use are these three
functions which you looked at yesterday
i hope most of you got to them if not
they're pretty easy to consider at the
moment
let's draw these things
you've got your original function
and there's our inverse okay now the
reason why we've got three sets of axis
is not more not six is because i want to
put them together so we can see the
relationship between them yes
so 2x minus four what does it look like
what's the wide set
negative four so it's somewhere down
here okay now it's climbing up and it's
pretty steep right so you should be able
to tell me without any calculation
what's the x intercept going to be
it's going to be 2 because it's going to
sorry this is negative 4. it's going to
go up and it should only go over
2 units by going up four units right so
okay here's my graph
and i'm calling that two all right in
the same way you should be able to by
now read off what are the important
things about the inverse function right
the inter intercept for the y value is
going to be up here at if i call that
negative 2
keep my scale reasonably consistent
there
and in the same way that we looked at
this we saw that's 2 that's negative 4
right you're going to get 2 and negative
4 over here which is exactly
what we ought to expect because
conceptually we are swapping x's and y's
so therefore when you stop x's and y's
you swap x and y
intercepts they exactly flip around
good so now we can draw this thing right
it should go through like so
okay
so being that we usually call this the x
and the y axis rather than giving them
the full names
this thing up here this is our original
function so i'll call that y equals f
right and this one over here the new one
that's y equals f
inverse
okay
good
quick question
where do they intercept
when they intersect i should say
what's the point of intersection
you go 2x minus 4 is equal to half x
plus two
subtract half x over you get
three on two x
that's a minus four swipe put that over
i get six
what's the value
it's four right
what's the y value
also four
four four okay my scale's a little off
but that's okay for now
four four right
keep that in the back your head let's
move on x squared minus one you've
already worked out the inverse can
someone tell me what it is
what's the inverse
you should have already worked out the
universe i believe it's the square root
of x plus one from memory okay
now because you've got a domain
restriction here right that's what gives
you a range restriction here domain
restriction range restriction right so
that's why you can say
because x is greater than or equal to
zero here
f inverse is greater than or equal to
zero here which is why you're able to
when you're working through the algebra
you can take just the positive square
root right this would have been a plus
minus if we didn't have this restriction
here and that would have been a problem
because it wouldn't have been a function
it would have been our
relation right so there's the
restrictions so what do each of these
look like when we put them together
let's stick them on x squared minus 1
that's going to look something like this
that's f what does the square root of x
plus 1 look like it looks just like the
square root of x but it has been shifted
in what direction
which way which way is it going
it's gone to the left hasn't it and you
can stick in a value to test that out
you can put in x equals minus 1 right so
therefore i'm over here
that's all right okay
so a little more information on here you
got your negative 1 and negative 1 there
because again the y intercept has become
the x-intercept okay
there's the shape there's a label mine's
a bit naughty it looks like it's coming
down a bit shouldn't really do that
okay again
where do they intersect
a point there
i'll let you have a think about it you
can work it out
okay one last one log of x plus one okay
i deliberately talked about this in
terms of shift because this is also a
shift isn't it it looks just like log x
which you're very familiar with except
it's moved
one unit to the
left actually exactly the same as this
hasn't it right so log x usually has a
vertical asymptote right where is its
vertical asymptote
it's usually at
x equals
zero so now i should be at x equals
negative one right so okay i'll draw
that in
where am i going to intersect with the
axes
i usually intersect at x equals one but
that's been moved over hasn't it so i'm
going to intersect right on the origin
so i get this kind of shape
okay
now have you already worked out what the
inverse is
has it all worked out what the inverse
is have you got that
i can't remember
e to the x minus one
yep okay
now what does this look like e to the x
minus one we know what e edx looks like
it's usually up here okay and you've got
a instead of a vertical asymptote i
should have labeled that shouldn't
matter
x equals negative one surprise surprise
because x's and y's are swapped now we
get a horizontal asymptote right where's
the horizontal asymptote
y equals minus one oh everything is
swapping i'm getting this now okay so
i'm going to draw this in
y equals minus 1 okay now what is the
normal
y-intercept
for e to the x what's the normal
y-intercept
it's usually
one isn't it okay but because i've gone
down one unit i'm now at
the origin okay
be careful how you draw this by the way
how many times
does this intersect with this
now it's a bit hard to to work that out
just looking at it okay because it looks
like it could sort of overlap it looks
like it could it might okay it doesn't
in a second we'll prove conclusively why
it doesn't but this is what be careful
when you draw this is what it wants to
look like
there you go there's my inverse
okay